Minor spoilers for "Strange World" ahead.
Unusual names, notable diversity, and an
important call to protect the planet. Here
are some of the things only adults
noticed in Disney's "Strange World."
"Strange World," the latest theatrical
release from Disney's Animation Studios,
follows Jaeger Clade, a legendary explorer
from Avalonia, a land that is surrounded by
mountains on all sides. On his greatest journey to
finally see beyond the mountains, his son Searcher
discovers a new substance that becomes the land's
greatest power source. However, Jaeger doesn't
make it back from the expedition. Years later,
Searcher lives on a farm with his son Ethan and
wife Meridian. However, it soon transpires that
the substance Searcher discovered years ago is
dying and needs to be saved. Searcher's family
is swept away on an adventure that leads them
to a strange world underneath Avalonia full
of alien creatures, and the missing Jaeger.
"Strange World" isn't afraid to wear its genre
influences on its sleeve. Right from the start,
the movie's love of pulp comics and adventure
stories shines in the form of visual homage. In
the intro to "Strange World," the credits
sequence begins in black-and-white before
showing the cover of an old school style
comic featuring all the characters of the
Clade family. It continues in this comic
book style as the introduction sets up the
prequel to the story, beginning
with Jaeger Clade's expedition.
"Pulp fiction" refers to cheap, campy
adventure comics published in the first
half of the 20th century, up until the 1950s.
The movie's directors have even revealed that
pulp magazines are one of the main influences on
"Strange World." During a press day for the film,
co-director and writer Qui Nguyen
revealed, via What's on Disney+,
Gabrielle Union gives an excellent performance
as mother, wife, and adventurer Meridian Clade in
"Strange World." Meridian is a strong supporting
character, acting as a rock for both husband
Searcher and son Ethan, and she even gets to
save them from time to time. But her character,
and specifically her name, has a deeper
meaning that reinforces her role in the movie.
"Brace yourself!"
Meridian is not necessarily a common name, but
it is an intentional choice that makes sense for
the character. Avid geographers will know that
"meridian" is an astronomical and geographical
term used by explorers and adventurers, which
refers to a line of longitude. The prime meridian,
for instance, is a centerline where longitude is
0°. In the movie, Meridian is Searcher's center,
as she grounds him. Additionally, while he
lives his life as a farmer, there is a small,
reluctant part of Searcher that wants to be an
explorer. The fact that his wife's name is a
geographical term is seemingly another clue
that he subconsciously longs for adventure.
The biggest theme that runs throughout "Strange
World" is the intergenerational conflict between
fathers and sons. Both Jaeger and Searcher,
and Searcher and Ethan, have their own issues
communicating and connecting with one another.
In fact, Searcher's relationship with his son is
informed by how his father treated him, which
touches on the theme of generational trauma.
However, "Strange World" also has a sense
of how male-centric this story might seem,
and it endeavors to prioritize its female
characters. Jaeger, Searcher, and Ethan find
themselves running from some angry wildlife, and
they find themselves scrambling through the flora
and fauna. Luckily, Meridian and President Mal
show up just in time to rescue them from turning
into alien food. In this moment, the women of
"Strange World" have an opportunity to shine.
"Ah, is this thing dangerous?" [scream]
In "Strange World," Alan Tudyk voices the
cute and gelatinous Splat. The blue blob is
one of two playful companions in the movie, the
other being the Clades' adorable three-legged
pooch Legend. Disney regularly includes cute
and cuddly companions in its animated movies
aimed at younger audiences, and "Strange
World" even acknowledges and pokes fun at
this practice. At one point in the movie,
a member of the crew notices Splat for the
first time and freaks out, getting very
excited. He then points to Splat and says,
"So cute. I wanna merchandise it."
This joke might go over the heads
of the film's younger audience,
but Disney's practice of creating
cute characters in order to sell
toys is well documented in everything
from "Strange World" to "Star Wars."
In "Strange World," each of the three Clade
men take journeys to find acceptance and peace
with their family in a multi-layered hero's
journey. The movie focuses most on Ethan,
the youngest character and the most relatable
to a young, diverse audience. Ethan struggles
with breaking out of the box that his father
is forcing him into and refuses to accept a
future as a farmer. Instead, Ethan longs to be
an explorer like his long-lost grandfather. So
when the two finally meet at long last and get to
know each other, they hit it off extremely well.
As "Strange World" continues, it becomes
clear that Ethan resembles his grandfather
and naturally takes on some of his mannerisms.
There's even a moment on the airship during which
Ethan and Jaeger stand next to one another
and they hold themselves in the exact same
pose. With their hands on their hips, front
foot outward and ready to take on the world,
the pose itself emphasizes the adventurer
spirit that the two share. It is a quick
moment and its significance is easy
to miss, but this theme is reinforced
throughout the movie as Ethan takes
after several other characters as well.
Jaeger isn't the only family member Ethan
has inherited traits and mannerisms from.
During "Strange World," it becomes
clear that Ethan's mother, Meridian,
has also inspired many of her son's
traits. From their need for conversation,
to the way they stand, Ethan and
Meridian share many similarities.
Ethan's shared traits with his mother and
grandfather only highlight how much distance
Ethan feels from his dad, Searcher. For instance,
throughout the movie, Ethan goes to everyone for
help except for his dad. On the surface, Ethan
seems to be more like Jaeger and Meridian than
his own father, and Searcher is painfully aware
of this fact and becomes hopelessly fixated on it.
But it's not until the final act that both father
and son realize what they truly have in common.
"I'm not my father."
Meanwhile, Searcher's relationship with
his own father is challenging. Plus,
that rocky relationship didn't get
any better when Jaeger abandoned him
and took off without warning. It takes
most of the movie for them to reconcile,
but Searcher and his father eventually start
to set aside their differences and warm up to
one another. They eventually spend some time
hanging out together, and start to bond after
the longest time apart. The difficulties they
face will be relatable to anyone who's ever
fallen out with a family member, or longed
to bond with a distant parent or relative.
At the start of the movie, Ethan's crush stops by
and drops off a new card for a game called Primal
Outpost. At first, it looks as though Primal
Outpost may share some similarities with Magic:
the Gathering. But it's not Magic that
Primal Outpost looks most similar to when
it's later played on the airship.
Instead, there's actually another
popular board game that Primal Outpost seems
to be both paying homage to and criticizing.
The setup for Primal Outpost is tile based, and
the objective of the game is to gain and trade
resources. While watching the movie, it's easy to
see that "Strange World" is evoking Settlers of
Catan, one of the most popular strategy board
games of all time. While the collectible card
game elements and some of the in-game rules
stray from what players can do in Catan,
Primal Outpost definitely feels like a
commentary on that game in particular.
Much of this critical commentary comes
from Ethan. As Jaeger and Searcher argue
about how to fight in the game, Ethan gets
increasingly frustrated. He suggests that
the point of Primal Outpost is to use
your resources to build a better world,
which is the exact opposite of the colonialist
fantasy of Catan and games of its ilk.
By the final act, it's become increasingly obvious
that President Mal and Searcher aren't in the
right. As Ethan bonds with Splat and finds awe in
the beauty of this new world they've discovered,
everything about the mission to save the
Pando plant starts to make him uneasy.
Towards the end of the movie, it's revealed to
Searcher and Ethan exactly how wrong they are,
solidifying one of the main themes
of "Strange World" in the process.
After a classic father son fight, Ethan runs off
the airship and Searcher follows. Eventually,
the two discover themselves in the location
Jaeger was trying to reach all along,
on the other side of the mountains. It's
here that they discover their planet is
a literal living being. Sadly, the being that
Avalonia sits atop is dying, and specifically,
it is being killed by the Avalonians
harvesting the Pando plant for their energy.
This twist turns a story that was already
about the environment into a full-on metaphor
for the climate change crisis facing our
planet. "Strange World" literally makes its
planet a living breathing creature, in order to
communicate the idea to its younger audience that
the planet is alive and can be harmed. In the
end, "Strange World" is about learning to fix
our mistakes but also about making sacrifices
in order to adjust to a new, healthier world.
After the story wraps up, the audience is
transported to one year later in a flash
forward. A voiceover from Ethan reveals what's
happened to Avalonia following the events of
"Strange World." In the epilogue, Ethan talks
about how the last year has been incredibly
difficult but that everyone has proven just
how resilient they are. Considering the fact
that "Strange World" is being released
at the tail end of the COVID-19 pandemic,
it's hard not to think that Ethan's
sentiment might have a deeper meaning.
"Strange World" is far from a throwaway
animation, and instead contains a crucial
subtext about climate change that mainly adults
and older teens will pick up on. But beyond that,
Ethan's talk of resilience appears to reference
the pandemic in particular. This moment serves as
a rallying call for all the viewers who fought
through a hard year, but must continue doing
the work to enact change. Ultimately, this
call to action is the overarching theme of
"Strange World," with the movie asking viewersto care for the planet before it's too late.